qu'est ce qui est fait un gars bonjour
vous êtes à barcelone alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé hier soir on parle de
violentes scènes d'émeutes
la venue des milliers de personnes se
sont réunies dans la rue en catalogne
alors plusieurs manifestations se sont
tenues simultanément c'était pour
protester contre l'arrestation du
rappeur catalan pablo hazell alors ce
dernier a été arrêté alors qu'il se
cachait dans une université de catalogne
alors il devait se présenter
la semaine dernière pour être incarcéré
mais il a préféré
il a préféré du coup compliquer son
arrestation qu'il considère injuste
alors il s'était retranché avec des
dizaines de sympathisants et hier l'un
des rassemblements les plus importants
s'est tenu à barcelone après une heure
de marche pacifique des manifestants se
sont déplacés dans le centre pour
détruire du mobilier urbain brûlé des
motos vandalisé des banques et des
commerces alors il ya eu des barricades
des charges policières
au total en catalogne il y a eu 33
blessés dont 17 policiers et 15
personnes arrêtées arrestation très
mouvementée de pablo hazell qui est le
symbole de la liberté d'expression pour
certains il a été condamné pour apologie
du terrorisme oui et aussi pour injures
à l'encontre de la couronne et aux
institutions de l'état
donc ça concerne 64 tweets qui ont été
publiés entre 2014 et 2016 parmi les
messages il y avait des messages
soutenant le thé a le groupe terroriste
basque et ça concerne également une
chanson sur l'ancien roi d'espagne juan
carlos
alors si la condamnation fait polémique
c'est parce qu'elle touche pour beaucoup
d'espagnols à la liberté d'expression
il ya d'ailleurs une tribune qui a été
signée par 200 personnalités du monde de
la culture comme le réalisateur pedro
almodovar où l'acteur javier bardem
il demande la libération de pablo hazell
ils demandent surtout que les excès
verbaux qui sont réalisés dans des
manifestations artistiques ou
culturelles ne concerne plus le droit
pénal afin d'exclure les peines de
prison l'essayer cinglant diack de
beerse barcelone merci beaucoup pour
tout ces précisions